I think development and environmentalism
are strange bedfellows they have to get
along but it's pretty easy for them not
to get along and I see so many examples
where development happens in what I
would subjectively just call in an
unlawful way oh here's a sand dune in
Florida it's only how much oh sure I'll
buy that yeah i'll put a McMansion here
what do you mean there's hurricane that
comes through here every year but
there's not just one hurricane there's
actually four hurricanes that come
through here every year I'll build it
anyway what do you mean the insurance
industry is pulled out because they're
not in sharing this region build it
anyway so part of that for me almost
borders on ignorance or stupidity or
just too much wealth but i believe that
development and environmentalism can get
along wonderfully if you're seeing all
the things are happening kind of under
the lead certification umbrella and just
the big shift that people have and
saying hey i can save money on my energy
costs if i do this to my house and oh I
live in near duke energy and they're
actually going to pay me to do some of
these things so i don't have to shell
out a hundred thousand dollars for solar
panels i can actually do it in a way
that's affordable to me that's pretty
cool